hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
today
we're definitely gonna go back
practically into your subconscious I
like you to remember when you were a
little kid walking through the video
store and you came across this don't act
like you haven't seen this video every
kid in the 80s has you know is it every
video store you could imagine and some
of us were unfortunate enough to rent it
pray for those people my friends for
those people so before we talk about
this movie let's take a look at a little
bit my pet monster was a hit toy in the
1980s and it was awesome
mostly because it was the only doll that
boys could play with without looking
like a pussy I mean come on a monster
that's a pet what boy's not gonna love
it
one of the big gimmicks was they he had
orange chains that you could break but
we found out later was made of plastic
and velcro fucking wires but
nevertheless the doll was awesome
sometimes later they made a cartoon show
that was based on the doll but that has
nothing to do with this this is an
hour-long made-for-tv movie that was
trying to cash in on their product as
quickly as possible
and trust me it shows is that we're
seeing no are we going to yes this is my
pet monster so the film starts out oddly
enough as a video game strange seeing
how my pet monster was everything but a
video game but hey Nintendo just came
out and we're ready to whore out
anything another odd thing that you'll
notice is that you see two other
monsters in this opening what was my
football monster which was a spin-off
toy and the other is beast over who's an
enemy of my pet monster and wouldn't you
know it neither of them are in this
fucking film we have them in the opening
if they're not gonna be in the rest of
the movie it's like having Harvey done
the first Batman movie and never use it
okay Ben example it's like having a
lizard man and the spider-man movies and
never using okay that also doesn't work
it's like having all these x-men and
never having them used to their full
potential that 8-bit opening we see a
happy family who I swear has the mother
from you can't do that on television we
see our main character is a little boy
named Max and his sister named melody
played by Allison court who's actually
done a shitload of voiceover work
including playing Claire and the
resident
bull games 100 is I could use some
flesh-eating zombies in the split but I
don't hold out much hope the kids go on
a field trip to a museum or an angry
scientist named Snyder is not amused to
be a tour guide to such ruffians must I
continue this idiocy I have more
important things to do but they take a
bunch of children on a tour of the
museum what can be more important than
these children they're the future of our
civilization I remember what I used to
pretend to be a monkey in eighth grade
god I was pitied there is to be no
eating in the museum is that clear is
that clear
next one a good one good one Bernie I'm
still writing that down when I get home
dear diary Bernie said another job today
god he's funny if only he knew the
feelings I had towards him if only I was
brave enough to tell
[Music]
so Schneider shows them these Babylonian
artifacts that looked more like the
ancient civilization of the Makkah tribe
the inscriptions on these tribal
artifacts revealed that these statues
possess the power to transform anyone
who stands before them into monsters
well thanks for using the scientific
term monster yeah that's a GU bring up
with this kid and constantly sucking
Bernie's dick like the Kevin Eubanks of
little white children in fact look at
that he was about to cop a feel I swear
to god he was about to cop a feel hey
that's a good one brain
I almost had my chance today but I
chickened out at the last moment
stupidly stupid
ah one day you will be mine
this is no bedtime story this is fact
fact that I have no facts to back up
with years of research and documentation
and for what so my colleagues can call
me crazy so insignificant bunches of
little brats like you can laugh at my
theories I'm a man of science not a tour
guide crackpot doc doctor needs a doctor
you need a muzzle okay did the writer
only have two lines a small talk in this
movie how many times are they gonna say
good one it said more times than Tommy
lacell says oh hi so the statute decides
to transform mags because they're 50
dude and his sister sees what's happened
to ya monster they go to dr. Schneider
to show what's happened to Mack says we
get to the point that really fucking
pissed me off as a kid excuse me sir
your statues turned me into a monster
what the hell is that it works my
parents aren't gonna like this I mean
what how the fuck does that look
anything like what's on the box that's
not my pet monster it's a fucking
radioactive Garfield plushie and it
what's the point if you're going to all
the work to make the monster on the
cover look like the toy if you're not
gonna make the monster and the movie
look like the toy I mean what's the
prayer oh my god it is the fucking toy
they just put the toy on the fucking
cover I never noticed it before but look
it's the plastic chains the cheap fur
it's the fucking toy that means that
they were so ashamed to show the real
monster from this movie that they just
decided to switch it with the toy so let
me get this straight the children's play
thing but you can get a toys for us for
like $15 it's a better special effect
than this animatronic Chuckie Cheese
nightmare you lied to me movie you lied
to me I thought I was getting this but
help instead I'm getting a little the
fucking crack baby where the wild things
are so if you were a little kid like I
was you were obviously very disappointed
by this point but fuck it it's better
watching this than going outside or
learning something so Snyder sees this
as his ticket to fame and fortune as he
locks the kids in the room my spider
senses are starting to tingle they're
not feeling very well yes we'll see that
they get home safely and you've got
monster powers so they managed to break
out of the room as Snyder spots them so
really how could anyone not spot them
it's a fucking blue monster walking
around and nobody seems to care is this
a normal occurrence at the Museum it
sure wouldn't shock me they probably
have a sign outside that says warning
may turn you into Technicolor Whoopie
diarrhea I mean at least it be a heads
up so Snyder's about to reveal the
monster to the head of the museum just
to find that the boy has changed back
they escaped as Snyder's being yelled at
and make their way back home their
brother rod comes home who I think is
played by Ellen sink before puberty and
he's dating a young lady named Stephanie
who's getting her poodle Tippi ready for
the dog show but Melanie goes upstairs
to find the maxis transformed into a
monster again you're reading a comic why
are you reading a comic you transformed
into a hideous blue Beast
how about an or AA blue Beast I mean am
I missing something it doesn't make any
sense I asked somebody about this hey
Rob you ever hear about the what what
happen to you what are you talking about
what happened to you oh yeah I'm a
dinosaur
do you mind I'm trying to read the far
side oh yeah sorry
Oh Gary Larson I like cows too I'm a
dinosaur
so Tippi starts to bug the kids as Rob
goes upstairs to get wow I guess monster
powers includes sloppily putting the
film in Reverse so his girlfriend is
angry because her poodles perm is messed
up as they tried to hide max it's my pet
monster
jefes it's almost as bad title dropping
as The Lord of the Rings movies only one
rupee you shall be the Fellowship of the
Ring to deny The Return of the King lost
so max changes back but it turns out the
siblings have an even bigger problem
than the scientific discovery of a
lifetime
look can you Tippie her perm back we've
got to get to be pretty dumped and fast
let's go something tells me these guys
got to get their priorities straight
Schneider follows them and mr. Bean's
cars they arrive at the dog salon and am
I the only one who's disturbed that
their abbreviation is KKK I mean what
kind of a store is this oh that explains
it the two guys that run the place read
in the paper that Tippi is the most
likely to win the dog show because I
guess that's really newsworthy when lo
and behold she's dropped right into
their lap it's gonna be our ticket out
of this dive but that's dognapping
is this really what we're gonna focus on
half the time there's a kid with
superhuman strength that looks like a
Navi fur ball and half the time is
focusing on this fucking total boy they
really know what kids want to watch
don't they okay they discover that max
fence into a monster every time he gets
hungry and also when schneider is around
to provide a convenient chasing
appearing before my very eyes wait a
minute did he just say look to a
tape-recorder god god you're a scientist
if you can't tell the difference between
a camera and a tape recorder you
shouldn't be in this field I said
something is approaching me go on Smith
it will just happen he fell off a window
now he's coming for a door must be one
of those Escher design buildings
thickest Schneider the slip but Max is
confused for a dog by one of the spawn
people yep I guess he's confusing it for
that rare breed of blue horned
Rottweilers that were really popular
back then but the sister comes in and
claims that she's picking him up
thankfully there's no paperwork in this
world so he just believes her and let
her walk out with it our heroes find out
about the dog mapping and try to see if
there's any way they can get tippy back
go back to Carl shop and rescue tippy
just like that sounds foolproof let's do
it
hey wait a minute I can't go anywhere
looking like this Wow I call that
incredibly racism I can figure out what
race they were trying to offend the
movie just got a sudden death attack out
of nowhere
[Music]
blood unfortunately Schneider is that
the dog spa waiting for them he forces
max to put himself in a cage or else
he'll hold his sister's hand tightly why
doesn't he just eat the fucker try these
on okay I know that's part of the toy
and everything but what the hell are
giant orange chains doing there where
the grooming a gorilla was the
Incredible Hulk playing is kinky night
games again I'll be back so max changes
back the luckily rod is there to save
them what they also had to save the
poodle because again that's the number
one concern in this movie however the
two goons are stupid enough to bring
tippy to the dog show and claim that
she's theirs never thinking for a minute
that maybe the original owners might
show up oh look the original owners
showed up dog thinking is hard
I'm not check you dog number I also love
the fact that they trust max like a dog
again to get inside and yet nobody at
the dog show Oh fucking dog show can
tell that he's not a dog even Stevie
Wonder with his nose blocked his fingers
in his ears and trapped in a box can
tell that he's not a dog but luckily max
is there to stop their getaway
hey guys oh wow you were really scary
till you start talking no you just sound
retarded what that truck hadn't broken
down those who'd moved might have gotten
away scot-free oh yeah the truck that
broke down and wrecked its own darauf
it's an everyday occurrence that foils
most getaways really great you know yeah
what I'm still a monster so it's the two
kids walk off into the sunset Snyder
talks to one of the monster statues and
gives us a very strange and actually
kind of creepy ending it was I who found
you and restored you to your ancient
splint I was chosen
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Jesus that's it there's no sequel to
this movie or spin-off show so that's
pretty much all we got when I was a kid
this give this shit out of me I mean
what happened did he turn into a monster
did he kill everybody what kind of sick
evil way is that to end a kids movie oh
who cares the movie is shit anyway
growing up with this toy you sort of
figure the idea would be well to have a
pet monster not have a boy turn into a
monster so even the set up is flawed but
on top of that it's a lazy story with
lazy writing and lazy animatronics and
plus that creepy ending for little kids
I mean it's not the worst but unless
there's a reason for it it's just
needlessly scary what was the director
thinking what was the idea behind this
if they're gonna call the director right
now and find out huh this isn't
nostalgia critic I want to know what the
hell you were thinking with the ending
of my pet monster
in fact what the hell were you thinking
with the entire movie in general well I
don't know what I was expecting I mean
it yeah yeah I saw the cover I still
rented in it yeah I watched him
willingly you know I'm not babysitting
anybody yeah yeah I'm 28 well it's um
it's kind of my job I yeah I uh
watch children's programming and tell
people what I think I'm lying
I'm very happy that you pity me eh yeah
we're done we're done
um just uh thank you for your time and
sorry - I think immunity - okay bye
I'm a nostalgia critic and and I got to
think of a few things
[Music]
yeah that's a good one brain